alter aber schaut man da leute ich habe
ich das mal ran gesund also das ist
meiner meinung nach ganz klar schimmel
alter ist das jetzt zu fällen das sieht
schön
[Musik]
ich glaube ich bin ein mensch meine
haare wachsen überdurchschnittlich
schnell die serie schon wieder so lange
diese camp hatte ich noch nie auf
bob der baumeister leute was jeder
herzlich willkommen beim ein video ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut er heute ich
habe gerade schon gebucht was ich
gesucht habt seht ihr wahrscheinlich am
titel und zwar das günstigste hotel was
ich heute noch spontan hier in meiner cd
gefunden haben hat mich 27 euro gekostet
und die meisten werden sich jetzt
sicherlich freuen
normalerweise sind wir doch von ihr
gewohnt dass du entweder das
schlechteste oder beste davon test heute
ist es halt mal das günstigste ich würde
auch gar nicht mehr sagen dass ich
unbedingt lieber das schlechteste
getestet hätten wir jetzt wahrscheinlich
mitbekommen in den trends war dann
wieder von den frankreich sehr sehr gute
kollegen von mir kennen uns schon echt
lange schöne grüße gehen auch daraus
seien also ich kann dir halt auch nur
von den youtube videos und habe schon
öfter gesehen dass die sachen auch mal
kopieren oder so war ich auch sagen muss
ich habe mich für das format die
schlechtesten besten restaurants und so
weiter nochmal aus amerika inspirieren
lassen und das halt deswegen weiter
gemacht einfach weil ich selber gar
nicht daran gedacht habe dass man das ja
bei möglichst vielen verschiedenen
restaurants oder essens möglichkeiten
machen kann trotzdem kann ich euch hier
mal kurz ein screenshot einwenden das
ist ein video das kam vor über einem
halben jahr oder so bei mir online und
da ging es schon um das schlechteste
burger restaurant zum beispiel also kann
man schon sagen dass ich der erste war
das halt gemacht hat aber damit die
frank boss die idee jetzt schon
weggeschnappt haben habe ich mich dazu
entschieden ist trotzdem zu machen und
einfach ins günstiges hotel zu gehen
weil da gibt es ja einen ganz bestimmten
unterschied und zwar muss es ja nicht
heißen günstig gleich schlecht ich würde
gern noch ein bisschen was erzählen
bevor wir richtig loslegen weil ich es
wichtig finde wenn ihr das nicht sehen
wollt oder werden wollte es gibt einfach
vor ja auf jeden fall muss ich sagen ich
bin ja schon etwas länger jetzt auf
youtube dabei und ich sag mal so ich bin
finanziell auf jeden fall in der guten
situation für mein alter fünfsternhotels
dann denke ich mir auch okay das finde
ich echt krass teuer aber wenn man in
der situation ist warum sollte man sich
nicht einen angenehmen aufenthalt können
das soll jetzt auch gar nicht blöd zu
bekommen oder so sondern einfach nur
sachlich so wie es ist ich bin
allerdings mensch ich kann auch in
postens gehen oder so ich kann mich zum
beispiel daran erinnern dass ich letztes
jahr silvester mit freunden von mir in
berlin unterwegs war und dort waren wir
auch unserem hostel was wirklich also
das war katastrophal da aber es war
extrem lustig und das ist ja dann auch
irgendwie nur zum schlafen also ich bin
der letzte der darum heute jetzt habe
ich hier allerdings sind und hilfe heute
nacht gebucht für 27 euro
das hotel hat irgendwie gar keinen stern
also ich hab mich ein bisschen
informiert und es gab auch noch sachen
die waren günstiger
das war dann allerdings so hotels mit
mehreren betten in einem zimmer also so
gemeinschaftszimmer wo man sich mit
fremden das zimmer teil ich habe
allerdings darauf wert gelegt dass ich
ein einzelzimmer habt damit ich es auch
gut unter die lupe nehmen kann wie es
dort aussieht dass ich eine dusche ab
und ja also dass man das halt so ein
bisschen anschauen kann auf jeden fall
war das jetzt so die wichtigsten sachen
die ich euch erzählen wollte ja dann
würde ich sagen wir sehen uns gleich im
auto wir fahren jetzt dahin checken wir
es mal ab und ich bin wirklich wirklich
mal sehr gespannt wie ich mich dort
fühle einfach aus dem grund weil ich so
was halt nicht gewohnt bin und
vielleicht denke ich mir dann ja auch so
eigentlich kann man es immer also
deswegen ist auch eine interessante
sache für mich selber und ja lasst nach
oben da wenn ihr eine andere idee hat
was man machen kann und wenn euch das
video gefällt würde mich sehr freuen und
abonniert auf jeden fall den kanal
letzte so leute was geht ab ich bin
jetzt angekommen im internet stand dass
das hotel über einen parkplatz verfügt
weil es gegen wie leider nicht so also
ich habe zumindest keinen gesehen außer
zwei parkplätze davor die beide belegt
waren und was ich durch zufall gerade
gesehen habe als ich wollte mich davon
eigentlich gar nicht leiden lassen und
das gar nicht anschauen und muss
objektiv zu betrachten denn die
bewertungen und zwar springt mir direkt
die zimmer waren sehr dreckig urin
flecken vom vorgänger auf der klobrille
und schimmel an der decke der nicht zu
übersehen war ins auge deswegen bin ich
jetzt mal gespannt was mich darin
erwartet aber ich packe meine
kann man jetzt im rucksack und filmen es
mit dem handy und dann sehen wir uns
gleich im hotelzimmer wieder leute das
sind nochmal so videos wo ich eigentlich
sage hey ich hab eigentlich überhaupt
keinen bock darauf dass jetzt zu machen
aber dann steht man so davor und weiß
ich muss das jetzt auch durchziehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
okay leute ich bin gerade ins zimmer
eingetreten ich habe jetzt direkt die
kamera herausgeholt und ich muss aber
sagen
der erste eindruck ist vollkommen in
ordnung also seid ihr bereit 321 boom
hier haben wir ein relativ großes bett
während sehr tisch schrank und das bad
also ich würd mal sagen bevor ich hier
eben etwas untersuche ich will nicht so
laut reden weil ich habe das gefühl die
kann mich unten hören wenn ich zu laufen
wollte ich euch noch ein zwei sachen
erzählen und zwar habe ich der das geld
gegeben das waren 40 euro und die
übernachtung kostet glaube ich 27 eur 75
und die hatte ein ernsthaft dass man im
taschenrechner ausgerichtet aber
vielleicht ist das ja vorgabe vielleicht
muss ich das keine ahnung zweite sache
die hat mich so richtig
selbstverständlich gefragt ob ich besuch
erwarte
dann habe ich natürlich gesagt nee ich
habe ja ein einzelzimmer gebucht ich
denke mal dass ein ganz typisches hotel
als ich jetzt vielleicht dumm an aber
für leute die ganz entspannt mal wie
sagt man am besten der schönsten
nebensache der welt nachgehen wollen und
das möglichst schnell und möglichst
günstig irgendwo halt neben der autobahn
hat es sich eventuell auch für
prostituierte kann ja auch sein ich habe
keinen plan weil sie hat gesagt wenn
besuch kommt kostet das 20 euro extra
und das schließt meiner meinung nach
halt daraufhin also wie gesagt erste
eindruck ist eigentlich voll in ordnung
für das geld war ich halt jetzt nicht
mehr erwartet um ehrlich zu sein ich
mache mich jetzt mal ein bisschen auf
die suche nach spuren
ob das wirklich so sauber ist wie es
auch schon erste weg aussieht und ich
idiot habe nicht mal hand schon
mitgenommen wie die das ja eigentlich
machen diesen serien und aber eine sache
die ich auf keinen selber titel wir
haben sogar handtücher
[Musik]
alter ist das jetzt zu fall
das sieht schon schreibt mir sehr gerne
mal in die kommentare wir dazu steht
aber wenn diese lampen die das schon
hart nach und nach deutlich aus oder
also heißen rotlichtmilieu irgendwie so
ein zimmer das erreichte wahrscheinlich
denken die leute dass ein aha da oben
ist wieder werbechef fläche in diesem
schrank lag einfach so ein zahlungsbeleg
vom 06 07 2010 also wiederum liegen kann
verstehe ich nicht ich habe das bett mal
abgezogen ich hätte gedacht die matratze
sieht viel schlimmer aus also wirklich
viel schlimmer ist ein fleck aber sonst
zeit wirklich alles sauber gut hier auf
dem kopfkissen wir unseren komischen
fleck gefunden ok und hier sind auch
einige komische flecken drauf aber das
ist eine sache da möchte ich mich auf
jeden fall nicht darüber beschweren weil
die bettdecke an sich und das ist glaube
ich selber habe ich noch obwohl doch
also hier ist eigentlich nichts dreckig
jetzt lege ich mich einfach auf den
boden aber ich muss sagen auch hier ist
alles sauber bisschen staubig aber das
bringen wir zur sache schließen als wenn
jetzt abgeschlossen dass das selbst das
macht doch gar keinen sinn leute könnten
ältere rauchmelder sein sieht aber
irgendwie auch auf sein mikrofon
schauen wir uns mal das bad an der star
trek was auch immer das hier ist das
klopapier ist auf jeden fall auch nicht
neu also das hat irgendwer schon mal
vorher genutzt finde ich jetzt auch
nicht so schlimm aber das hier könnte
man schon mal saubermachen
dann mache ich das halt also ich muss
sagen auch dass bahr ist finde ich
sauber wir haben ja sogar so eine
fußmatte meine eigene dusche
also der duschvorhang leicht ranzig aus
aber das ist einfach das muster alter
aber schaut man da leute ich habe ich
das mal ran gesund also das ist meiner
meinung nach ganz klar schimmeln ich
weiß ja dass die kamera jetzt so gut
aufzeichnet wir sind echt aussieht aber
dass sie dass sie ganz böse aus möchte
man da nie gekannt ich mache davon mal
kurz ein foto aber das ist so eine sache
da hört es bei mir auch weise das finde
ich wirklich widerlich eine so stark
habe ich das noch nie gesehen also da
muss ich wirklich sagen nach an der
decke haben wir das gleiche problem
leute da oben kann man es sehen oder was
denn sonst diese schwarzen flecken ich
wurde über fehler ist alles und lernt
euch dass man hier noch ein im zimmer im
sich die decke geht aber auf jeden fall
eine sache eine ganz wichtige sache die
wir vergessen haben ich habe noch gar
nicht in die toilette geguckt meines gab
er die rezension dass sie im urin
flecken sind und so deswegen schauen wir
jetzt mal in die toilette ich habe jetzt
leider keine uv lampe dabei natürlich
ist das coolste was zu haben aber
solange man jetzt noch zieht also für
mich sieht das eigentlich server aus hat
auf jeden fall jemand sauber gemacht das
einzige was mich so richtig schockiert
ist dass da bei schimmel im hotelzimmer
finde ich absolut kannst also weil es ja
auf jeden fall gesundheitsschädigend und
in seinem hotelzimmer möchte ich dann
ungern schlaf auch wenn sie jetzt im
schlafzimmer nicht der fall ist ja okay
leute ich habe mich jetzt noch mal hier
an diesem wunderschönen tisch gesetzt
ich muss sagen ich habe jetzt leider
nicht wirklich einen vergleich aber so
schimmel habe ich noch nie in irgend
einem hotelzimmer oder hostel oder weil
das hier wird sogar als hotel
abgestempelt oder verkaufen hatte ich
persönlich noch nie auf das oft vorkommt
weiß ich nicht ich würde mal sagen er
nicht natürlich liegt man das sehr auf
den irgendwelchen dokus oder so dass es
natürlich solche hotels gibt aber das
ist jetzt bei mir hier wirklich ist
hätte ich um ehrlich zu sein nicht
gedacht das ist halt für mich dann schon
so ein punkt warum das hotel auf jeden
fall drei sterne haben sollte einfach
weil man davon ausgehen kann dass solche
sachen nicht vorhanden sind was ich auch
noch sagen wollte ich habe mir das video
von den fans natürlich auch angeguckt
und bei denen sagen so kondome auf dem
boden habe waren im waschbecken und so
weiter und das ist für mich halt
offensichtlich fake also als wenn sowas
einfach vorkommen ich hoffe mal das
wissen die meisten von euch und ich
würde dieses hotelzimmer jetzt mal ja
als auf jeden fall eher schlecht
einstufen
aber für den preis kann man halt auch
nicht mehr erwarten nur das mit dem
schwimmbad finde ich kann man trotzdem
verhindern dass geht für mich gar nicht
kann noch mal den fernseher getestet da
geht sogar an
also habe ich mir auch gedacht dass da
an geht wieso nicht ja leute was geht ab
ich bin natürlich schon wieder zu hause
das video habe ich auch schon soweit
fertig gestellten ich habe noch kein
ende gemacht eine sache die ich auf
jeden fall noch sagen wollte wo ich mir
jetzt so denke und zwar war ich gerade
noch mal auf der hotelseite weil ich ja
den screenshot machen musste wie teuer
das ist und ich weiß nicht das habe ich
jetzt irgendwie für 720 euro war das ja
oder habe ich dasselbe buch wenn man es
jetzt früher bucht für nächste woche
kostet sogar noch ein bisschen weniger
wenn man allerdings für im juli buch
kostet es einfach 147 euro also so ist
das da angegeben
und da denke ich mir keine ahnung woran
das liegt könnt ihr gerne mal eure
vermutung in die kommentare schreiben
das war es vom video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen abonniert selber gerne
meinen kanal schreibt beiträge dem was
ich noch zu testen und in die kommentare
und wir sehen uns hart rein